let's see who else we can get to here
why don't we go to our caller from the
four one four area code caller from four
one four if you can hear me tell me who
this is tell me where you're calling
from and what's on your mind today I did
this is Chris from the Milwaukee area I
was hungry
I was wondering since this has gotten
really little to zero airtime in the
corporate media not to my surprise but
the civil suit that was pending against
Jeffrey Epstein that was settled from
multiple victims of his pedophilia and
more specifically what I wanted to ask
you is how come or why do you think that
the links between Jeffrey Epstein and
Donald Trump haven't been thoroughly
investigated especially since there was
a complaint filed against Trump in 2016
that he had raped a 13 year old girl in
1994 in Jeffery up Stein's Manhattan
home yeah and they also had someone who
was willing to corroborate that stories
be it witness but the complaint was
withdrawn due to like threats of
violence I was just wondering if you had
heard about that I absolutely have yes
we've actually talked about that and so
when I talk about the sexual assault
claims against Trump I include that
there is an allegation that Trump
participated and correct me if I'm wrong
it was like a gang rape of a 13 year old
girl wasn't it yeah they said Epstein
and Trump and someone else tying her
down to a bed and thing there's a couple
views on this one would be the reason we
haven't heard more about it is because
everybody who's willing to talk about it
has been threatened with violence as as
you're saying the other side of it would
be that there are more sort of technical
legal things that are going on including
that there have at one point and I'm
going just from memory here there were
questions about whether the alleged
victims were actually identifiable and
willing to come forward and an issue of
Jane Doe vs named accusers but I think
that without knowing every legal
that has been taken there's no question
that there is a legal effort to suppress
going on and I don't know if we'll ever
know the truth of that story the
allegations are disgusting and you're
right that there was at least at one
point alleged corroboration and I hope
that we learn more about it because it's
quite frankly disgusting and horrifying
I agree and it's just so sad that
someone you know is in the highest
office in our nation and then just has
such a horrible background but yes these
are the days we live in I go indeed they
are yep appreciate the call thank you so
much great to hear from you I'm out of
time for calls thanks to everybody who I
spoke to I'm trying to enforce a
one-question rule a couple people said
David when so many people are holding
don't let people ask
two or three questions I think I stuck
to that today but alas I didn't get to
everybody next week more calls quick
break and back after this one of today's
sponsors is Skillshare which is an
amazing online learning community that
offers thousands of high-quality classes
on almost any topic first 500 people who
click the link under this video will get
two entire months of totally free access
to every single class offered by
Skillshare they've got classes on
everything from design video editing
photography business technology cooking
meditation even classes on personal
productivity I know you'll be able to
find something on Skillshare that
fascinates you or even something that
will help you in your everyday life
classes are taught by real people who
care about what they're teaching I just
took a really great class on more
advanced video editing techniques the
david pakman show is giving you two
months of free access to every class
they offer when you click the link under
this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under 10
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of Skillshare but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up